previously on TV since hey trees what do
you think you're doing this episode does
not contain the x-files theme songs
trying to make the x-files feel like a
true story show is about the [ __ ]
this bullet OOD ever inspired by actual
documented accounts so someone wrote
something down and then you use that as
a jumping off point to create fiction
about it yeah I'm sure all the half
man/half fluke worms killer cockroaches
and parasitic detachable twins in the
world appreciate your documentarian
integrity also come on guys our actual
documented accounts just documented
accounts also also reading a man kids
are dying from being abducted into an
alien testing lab out here this is no
time to play the pronoun game I actually
dig the typeform location titles but why
start on the FBI building sign if you're
going to literally spell it out for us
anyway double established shot me show
and just like that the endless Princess
Leia metal bikini sexual role-playing
requests we're retired and the red wig
and female business suit attire
fantasies began are you familiar with an
agent named Fox Mulder yes I am by
reputation
because if you work we have to do all
that heavy expositor ourselves and it
sounds so much better coming from you
he's an oxford-educated psychologist who
wrote a monograph on serial killers and
the occult this is how you know Mulder
by reputation
that's like stalker level detail there
either she's a savant has a background
on every single agent in the FBI or her
deep knowledge of Mulder is super
convenient are you familiar with the
so-called x-files role commercials
you have to take my word for it but damn
the music in this is almost a direct
ripoff or the music from Twin Peaks not
to mention that we start with a young
girl found dead in a small coastal
Northwest town and it's clear that Chris
Carter is not afraid to let his twin
peaks' boner fly at full mast at all
times agent Mona I'm Dana Scully I've
been assigned to work with you I know we
were supposed to see Mulder's
personality in this piled high desk that
even includes a stack of papers under a
freaking phone but if he was expecting
her why did he show up Scully's thesis
in this big pile of papers just in a
month from her work laws of physics
rarely seem to apply I didn't realize
David Duchovny directed the Fast and
Furious movies
Oregon female age 21 No
explainable cause of death autopsy shows
nothing Fox News you know this Oregon
female she's the fourth person in her
graduating class to die under mysterious
circumstances maybe it's a bit weird
that all four died in less than four
years under so-called mysterious
circumstances
but not sure this is enough to jump to
alien Theory territory right now wait
Scully just got to Mulder's office did
it really take the entire workday to get
from the administrator's office down to
the basement manspreading
if we don't have any kind of latching
technology in 1992 how on earth is every
single one of these overhead bins coming
open average to exhume one of the other
victims bodies you're not squeamish
about that kind of thing are you I don't
know I've never had the pleasure to see
a dead body
let's go we went to med school victim
after graduating high school he spent
time in a state mental hospital treated
for post-adolescent schizophrenia this
was the most appropriate time to bring
it up in public right next to this
extremely loud machinery it's probably a
safe bet ray Soames never meant to
varsity basketball team I have an FBI
recently but probably also a safe bet
that this is not an appropriate way to
conduct yourself during an investigation
yeah I want tissue samples and x-rays
I'd like blood typing toxicology and a
full genetic workup Scully balking at
this these are all scientific tests he's
talking about it's not like he wants to
waive a divining rod over the body and
then have an energy reader come in and
make an assessment if she doesn't think
it's alien then doing the tests and
proving it should be her default mo I
know this is super nit picky welcome to
the channel hope you enjoy yourself but
who circles stuff in this way is that
marker ink or paint whatever it is it
looks like it started and stopped about
five times while creating that circle
also that circle mind you isn't even
needed I mean if you can't examine this
x-file x-ray with enough expertise to
find the exact place this extraneous
extraction exists perhaps you should be
expelled from all future
extraterrestrial exploits well you might
find it difficult certainly in Billy
miles case Billy's experiencing what we
call a waking coma for today's example
of conversations that don't miss a beat
even though the participants have
obviously covered a long distance
between sentences we submit this
nonsense
seriously Mulder and Scully just let
that question hang all the way from
their outdoor stroll to this building
and then into this room
by who by what you don't really believe
that do you have a better explanation
wouldn't any explanation be a better
explanation clearly if someone is going
around throwing a ring in towns and
coffins there's some weird being done by
humans in this town oh there is that you
yes go hit a giant spotlight in my
pocket and I'm making loud mechanical
sounds kind of a question is this
Special Agent Dana Scully FBI dropped
your weapon I'm with the County
Sheriff's Department where we make it a
policy to walk up on you in a very
sneaky and suspicious way with huge
bright lights behind us so that you'll
think we're aliens what do you think it
is to the campfire Oh Mulder it's not a
campfire may have come from a campfire
or maybe it was a campfire but it's most
certainly not present tense eight
freakin campfire hour Mulder and Scully
having a stupid question contest are
they mosquito bud jeez took him long
enough to tell her it was pervy Mulder
another one of his nicknames at the
academy she just disappeared out of her
bed one night just gone vanished no no
no phone calls no evidence of anything
sweet the show is going to be about the
search form older sister and at the very
least will not take 11 seasons in a
couple of movies to wrap that up with a
satisfactory and not at all confusing
answer right where the hell did all
these candles come from is it common
practice for a hotel to provide you with
multiple candles or any candles hello
what who is this answering late-night
phone calls with hello what who is this
in a television show cliche cool camera
shot there grimmy Carter but why would
this sheriff light this road flare this
far away from where he was eventually
planning to put it I'm scared I might
die like the others
none of these 89 are thought to I don't
know leave the town I love this place
every day it's like Halloween more like
Halloween 3 but semantics the boy in the
hospital the vegetable that's racist it
all fits a profile of alien abduction
yes Scully would be great at writing TV
sins also gotta side with Scully here
what profile of an alien abduction
involves essentially comatose patients
getting up in the middle of the night
and killing their friends I guess you
changed his bedpan nobody else here's
gonna do it really in a hospital I mean
if you work in a hospital isn't that
just part of the job literally what is
she looking for Mulder take a look at
this you better come take a look at this
cliche also
what the hell's going he's standing
right [ __ ] there can you just point
at the feet and say look I know they get
some samples but the fact that his feet
are dirty at all is a pretty good
indicator he's been up right you said it
yourself yeah but you have to write it
down in your report because molder just
doesn't have to do reports
so if scones are left Billy in the
hospital and came straight here in their
vehicle how did young miles cover the
miles it took to get here faster than
native now the dad has a change of heart
Billy's killed what five other
classmates and Moltar saying don't
somehow gets him to do something
different
there's a reason cigarette smoking man
is one of the greatest TV villains of
all time it's because the show realized
that the paranoia of mystery and
controlling powers was stronger than
explicit backstory and villainy the show
did a lot of things right but this may
have been the right of statists a
one-way glass right as Mulder just
looking at himself in the mirror somehow
he knows Scully is standing right there
yes tomorrow but like everyone else in a
film or television show Scully hangs up
rudely instead of just [ __ ] saying
goodbye like a normal human being
file this under w for weird doohickey
thingies for a shadowy government cabal
that has shown a pension for destroying
evidence your evidence room sure has a
lot of evidence this isn't a monster of
the week episode
I don't feel comfortable with that you
believe in the existence of
extraterrestrials oh god please no x
marks the spot really wants me to read
now I'm here to solve this case Mulder I
want the truth you can't handle the
truth my name is theresa nemman you've
got to protect me come with me if you
want to live I love this place every day
is like Halloween trick-or-treat what's
he looking at good because all my filth
is in alphabetical order this for
example was under H for a toy